so
i have to start with the first thing
being that was it a prerequisite
of being cast in this film that you had
to have been in fargo
i mean i've never even seen the show i
think
he's just got that extra
power or something i don't know yeah
um being serious for a second um one
charlie ever
i've spoken to him a few times and i
really love his work he's a very unique
individual with the way he thinks
and what he puts on screen can you sort
of talk about what he was like to
collaborate with
on set and if anything kind of surprised
you oh he was
the best to be on set with he let you
kind of
find your way with that and get lost
in it as well and and let you fail like
as well
which is a real like gift to like say
well we're going to just
fail sometimes and that's where you find
magic i guess sometimes
um and he's i guess what surprised me uh
was that he's incredibly fast on a
scooter
um and we would often have scooter races
and he was very he was confident in that
so i was surprised by that
[Music]
just i was not expecting that answer
he's just a really
i mean you you've spoken with him he's a
well i i've never interviewed him so i
don't know what that's like but
he's just a really gentle
soul too and a really honest so
there's no no pretense everything that's
coming out of him
seems to be the truth you know to him
um and yeah that's what you
want and a collaborator so kind of
director
one of the things that i love about
charlie's work and i think a lot of
people love is that
there's a lot open to the viewer's
interpretation that is especially true
in this film there's a lot
open to the viewer what is it like
reading the script for the first time
and did charlie sort of tell you
anything going in about what he was
trying to do
or was it sort of like read the script
tell me what you think
i remember i waited for a while before
i asked real
questions about what was going on
thinking well
you know i'll figure it out here in just
a minute
and then it was getting down to that
time and then i think i finally just
broke down
[Music]
something um which
he did in a general way that still
left it wide open um
but yeah jesse did you have those
yeah i think it was the same
like i mean when you're reading at first
you're
it's the same property experience as
viewing at first you know
they're so there's so much
happening and so much sub text and so
and so much emotion that
is kind of unnerving in uh
that when you read it first there's
you're just like
kind of a bit um you're shook and you're
awake and and
yeah it feels exciting and and kind of
scary at the same time um but
charlie never yeah he never i think it's
a very confident director
doesn't feel like he has to place his
own ideas on top of
a story he's just asking questions and
asking questions of you
which you will have your own
understanding of
depending on where you are in your own
life and i think that's a really
yeah an amazing thing to to feel
strong in doing a lot of actors i've
spoken with
have told me that they wish they could
reshoot the first two days
on a lot of projects because it's about
you're not as comfortable on those first
two days and you sort of fall into the
character and then
we should go back in time have you guys
ever felt that
definitely but i think it's
to me it's it's double-edged
like sometimes i guess especially early
on
you know when you're more critical you
think i could have done a better job but
even when it's when it's great
i feel like most times i could just
start over and do it all again
because there's a it feels
especially with something like this
there's an alternate universe where we
had
a couple of weeks to rehearse and that's
a completely different movie
and it's not that i even think that
would have been better but it's just
it's just a different movie there are an
infinite
number of ways this movie turned out you
know so
and it's just so much fun um
i would i would do it all again
i'm not sure if you're adding anything
uh yeah i i think i s like second one
for jesse said but also i i don't think
in a way to get out of your own head in
this place and like let go
and um the worst thing you could have
done
is preempt what you thought a scene was
going to be like in this film because
it never revealed itself like that it
was always its own
being and um and if anything
the most ex you know there's some scenes
where you know
you get a feeling when you're when
you're riding the wave of something and
there are some scenes where
we were we were kind of feeling
maybe we weren't but actually maybe
that's part of the struggle as well is
like the chaos of
of and the playables and the fragility
of what
is is part of it like you're kind of i
always want to find the chaos because
that's when something real comes out
you know if something becomes a habit
that's when it becomes boring
and the pace that also lent itself to
just that that exact feeling of the film
you know
there was no way we were going to shoot
past a certain tape
and that was accepted so
on that note i have to go i'm just going
to say congrats thank you so much for
talking to me
have a fantastic day speed dating